good morning students can anyone tell me
the answer please I will see you on
Tuesday wait a minute that's not what
happens in real life actual MIT
undergraduates often come to class on
three hours of sleep sometimes they're
afraid to volunteer what might be the
wrong answer they're not always paying
attention and they might not understand
what you thought you explained well so
how can you be a successful TA at MIT
try thinking of your class as a popular
website that visitors come back to again
and again what makes a website user
friendly user friendly to me means that
in order to complete the task at hand
the website is designed the way that's
illogical yeah um I feel like format
just a clean simple format is really
nice it's not cluttered and messy the
most important things for a
user-friendly website is a clear
interface simple categories and a search
option and an accessible language so
being able to find things very
efficiently and quickly is definitely
pretty important I think it's more user
friendly when you can actually
understand what you what they want you
to do and where things are being able to
find the right things in a way that's
easy
in other words a user-friendly website
we designed with the
we were thinking that to make the user
feel happy and easy instead of making
the computer engineers to feel happy
what if the engineer is a teacher and
the user a student the main principle of
accessibility should be the same a
website should be simple clean and also
like should have where you want to go
right away and a teacher should be able
to judge where the students need what
the students needs where the students
want to go and adapt in that way I guess
like the search button will be asking
the TA asking the professor for more
information it's not necessarily that
everyone is going to be your friend but
it's more about being easy to understand
in terms of having a clear interface
just a simple structure of the class
some users can expect to like the
lecture Coast's the lectures go the same
way the recitation go the same way and
something that students can expect so
organization and predictability are key
to the user friendly class planning that
way in a logical session where you like
review things that are necessary and
then going into problem practice
problems and then going into going over
what were the right answers I thought
that was like pretty user friendly for
student cuz it was a good review and
then get practice so I was like logical
the TA acts as a guide for the students
it's important you
it's will explain the learning
objectives of the class early on have
just like an air of confidence and be
able to direct the recitation a very big
expectation in the recitation is for the
TA to provide us with the big picture of
the concepts but ta is approachable and
supportive you need to feel that you can
approach them and ask questions without
any problem AB knowledgeable the most
important thing for ica is that they
have to have a very solid understanding
of what's going on in the material but
is knowledge enough unfortunately it's
not enough to simply be knowledgeable
about the subject it's the way you
presented the way communicated they're
all very smart I know they all know what
they're talking about so it's just how
they can communicate that to us so what
is good communication in the
user-friendly classroom the biggest
thing that came across my mind was
definitely like how they answered
questions and like the feedback they got
from the students how they responded to
that it's not the same when they read a
paper and they just read the problem in
the board and solved the problem then
explaining why is it going like this or
why is it working like this I think just
a willingness to clarify is very very
important being patient and being able
to explain the same concept in different
ways and they can actually explain it to
you I'm a basic undergrad level in the
next videos we will learn communication
skills and strategies to meet students
expectations and create a user-friendly
classroom
you